ja dass er hinter mir das ist atlas der
größte teilchendetektor der welt im
größten teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
der large hadron collider kurz lhc am
cern in genf das ist übrigens auch die
größte forschungsanlage der welt aber es
geht noch mehr und so startet jetzt die
aufrüstung der anlage statt einer
milliarde protonen kollisionen pro
sekunde soll der beschleuniger schon
bald fünf milliarden schaffen wie der
ausbau des lhc genau vonstatten geht und
was das ganze mit außerirdischen zu tun
hat jetzt den klicks und science fiction
direkt vom lhc aus dem cern hierbei
games herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ja bislang ist der ringförmige tunnel
hier 100 meter unter der erde also unter
diesem gebäude ganze 27 kilometer lang
doch die europäische organisation für
kernforschung cern rückt jetzt mit
baggern und bohrmaschinen allerdings
unterirdisch neue tunnel stücke werden
angebaut werden leistungsstärkere
magnete ein gesetz kommen wir uns gleich
an steht hier einer direkt um die ecke
und insgesamt sollen auch mehr protonen
kollidieren
daher auch der name des lhc projekt in
das eine milliarde euro investiert
werden denn wenn mehr protonen
kollidieren wird es in der anlage auch
stärker leuchten daher der begriff hai
lu - it i was so viel heißt wie hohe
leistungsfähigkeit leuchtkraft etwa 130
neue magnete werden dafür benötigt
darunter 24 supraleitende quattropole
die den strahl fokussieren hier liegt
bereits eine also nicht ganz klein diese
dinger mehr als 1,2 km der aktuellen
anlage werden umgebaut und optimiert
zudem sollen die maschinen besser für
wartungsarbeiten zugänglich gemacht
werden und außerdem auch effizienter
werden dazu der projektleiter oliver
brüning es ist wie bei einer
hausrenovierung man baut eine neue
heizung ein
die effizienter ist aber um mehr zu
heizen braucht man mehr holz und
entsprechend größere keller
so ganz stimmt dieser vergleich dann
aber doch nicht denn die pläne des cern
sind gewaltig und so muss so manches
material das verbaut werden soll erst
einmal entwickelt werden
so werden beispielsweise kabel gebraucht
die die deutlich stärkeren magnetfelder
überhaupt außerhalb zudem werden auch
neuartige kabel aus magnesium die porit
entwickelt die für den stromtransport
von den steckdosen zu den magneten
einsetzbar sind dadurch dass das
material eine supraleitende verbindung
ist wird der energieverbrauch für den
betrieb der magnete gesenkt eine
entwicklung die auch für den einsatz in
der industrie interessant sein könnte
bei den experimenten des large hadron
collider kurz lhc geht es hauptsächlich
um protonen kollisionen die
forschungsteams erhoffen sich durch den
ausbau der anlage bislang unbekannte
elementarteilchen auf die schliche zu
kommen seltene phänomene zu untersuchen
und genauere messungen durchzuführen
kriegt will man sich weiter mit dem
higgs-boson beschaffen dass 2012 ja hier
entdeckt wurde
das upgrade des lhc soll es dann schon
bald erlauben seine eigenschaft näher zu
definieren das higgs boson kurz das ist
ja für die masse von materie warum
zuständig und zudem sehr genau wollen
sie es messe wie es entsteht zerfällt
und auch mit anderen teilchen
interagiert konkret will das cern die
anzahl der kollision pro sekunde um von
einer milliarde auf mindestens 5
milliarden erhöhen
dafür sollen nicht nur soll nicht nur
mehr protonen zirkulieren sondern der
zusammenstoß auf 8 statt 16 mikrometer
fokussiert werden
dazu der cern generaldirektor fabiola
gianotti der ausgebaute lhc wird die
ursprüngliche mission erweitern und die
eigenschaften von teilchen wie dem higgs
boson mit grösserer präzision messen und
die fundamentalen bestandteile des
universums immer tiefer erforschen der
aufbau der anlage kommt gerade recht
denn wenn man es genau nimmt und auf den
punkt bringt läuft der physik die zeit
davon
auch wenn das sogenannte standardmodell
der letzten jahre immer weiter
perfektioniert wurde ist allen klar dass
es dringend überarbeitet werden muss
denn bestimmte formen von energie und
materie wie etwa die dunkle materie und
die dunkle energie passen einfach nicht
in dieses modell doch sie existieren
davon sind zumindest die meisten
forscher und forscherinnen immer noch
überzeugt und denn sonst könnte das
universum nicht expandieren und galaxien
würden sich in den außenbereichen ganz
viel langsamer drehen
doch genau das passiert eben gar us ihn
drehen sie schnell das universum
expandiert und so könnte der optimierte
lhc dabei helfen nach den fehlern in der
theorie zu suchen und im besten fall
eine richtung vorzugeben dies dann mit
der physik weitergehen könnte oder eben
vielleicht beides zu widerlegen so oder
so wird es wahrscheinlich bahnbrechende
entdeckungen geben die bauarbeiten
wurden zunächst oberirdisch gestartet
mitte juni wurde dann mit den ersten
arbeiten begonnen vor allem an zwei
hauptstandort nämlich in der schweiz und
in frankreich sind umfangreiche
tiefbauarbeiten notwendig weil der lhc
der geht hier durch zwei länder hier
entstehen neue gebäude neue schächte
unterirdische hallen und
verschiedene anlagen für kühlung lüftung
und elektrizität der plan sieht vor dass
der beschleuniger ab 2025 als super
beschleuniger durchstarten kann mit
allen neuen messinstrumenten magneten
und kabeln es bleibt also spannend und
wird noch spannender und ein wirklich
spannender fact am rande
gestern abend habe ich mich lange mit
einem mitglied des staats haben atlas
detektor unterhalten was diese anlage
mit außerirdischen zu tun hat es ist so
ziemlich die einzige maschine die eine
intelligente spezies bauen muss um sich
weiter zu entwickeln wenn es also stimmt
dass es wahrscheinlich sehr viele
solcher zivilisationen gibt dann muss es
diese maschine unzählige male im weltall
geben vielleicht ist sehr eine spur zu
außerirdischen zivilisationen wenn er
keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte
abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst
kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich um garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks ohne social media
abonnieren
deshalb da gibt es immer das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
und nicht natürlich nicht die leute
vergessen genau
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken herkunft der geister
teilchen enträtselt bis dann bleibt dran